hello everyone I'm Jessica Tarlov along
with Rachel Campos Duffy Joey Jones
Dagan McDowell and Jimmy phela It's Five
O'Clock in New York City and this is the
five
President Biden is out in Nantucket for
Thanksgiving and grappling with the most
consequential decision he'll have to
make in his nearly 50-year political
career so far will he run for
re-election the president who just
turned 80 taking time to talk with his
family at the dinner table on what his
next steps should be calling it quote
ultimately a family decision it comes as
he sees some other big leader and
leaders in his party like Nancy Pelosi
step aside as Democrats cry out for a
new generation
so whatever he decides is sure to send
shock waves throughout the Democratic
party and the country but Biden isn't
too eager to say what's on his mind
thank you thank you
and as President Biden searches for an
answer on 2024 his potential successor
vice president Kamala Harris isn't doing
herself any favors with awkward moments
like this
hello
thank you hello
decides to run his campaign is likely to
look like this the White House is
putting out what it calls a Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving menu of accomplishments
that people can use to talk up the
president around the holiday table
I certainly used it myself but before we
get to talking politics how was
everyone's Thanksgiving Jimmy JT it was
amazing but my family doesn't know the
difference between hospitality and a
hazing ritual so it starts out as like
this friendly thing two hours in it just
sounds like a Civil War battlefield
everybody's moaning and achy and hurting
and then we burped and ate again it was
great well if you don't get stabbed in
the back of a hand with a fork it's a
good day it's not a meal I was sick so I
didn't get off the sofa or really
getting out of the bed I love how Jimmy
acquitted what happened to me on the
battlefield
[Laughter]
was great we uh we had our actual
traditional dinner on Tuesday came up
here on Wednesday got to uh host on the
couch yesterday and then we went and saw
the Rockettes and ate Bill's burgers and
uh my bank account is depleted but my
belly and heart is full well maybe if
you weren't trying to tip the Rockettes
you'd have more money
listening Don't Make It Rain I wish I
would have said closer
so it was the Rockettes for your
beautiful daughter or yeah there's
something for everybody
how many kids did you have home uh we
only had seven only seven this time but
it was a wonderful time everyone really
um prepped so I put on my Instagram like
uh my kids did that whole like fast
forward out of every all of us prepping
um you know on Instagram so yeah we
worked all together the day before so
actually it wasn't too bad yesterday and
Sean fried the turkey Sean's face looked
puffy this morning on TV and I was like
what was he doing left he was up late
yeah
this woman cooked the night before
hosting on Fox and Friends I did listen
well but I had help I had help big
families mean teamwork yeah I just love
that you pulled an Elon Musk and laid
off two kids that's hilarious sorry
we're downsizing
all right so let's shift gears to what I
presume is going to be some Biden
bashing from you guys
um Julie I'll go to you first
um where do you think Biden is going to
land on this obviously the midterms went
better for Democrats than expected my
guess is he's going to run is that what
you think as well I think you I think
yes I think you will run I don't see why
he wouldn't unless he has true old age
creep in which I think is an absolute
possibility I mean heart disease
Anything could happen to someone that
gets older I mean it's just kind of part
of it so true health problems could
prevent it but if he feels like he can
physically do it I don't know why he
wouldn't I mean he he does have a
mandate he can take to the Democrat
Party right now from the midterms
doesn't mean that it's a winning
strategy for 2024 but within his party
he's got a mandate all right I like that
answer Jimmy let's see if you can live
up stop standard
um so Biden's popularity has been
ticking up since the midterms which is
what typically happens when there's a
good performance but let's say that he
decides not to run and then there's a
huge free-for-all going on are there any
names and put yourself in the mentality
of your show yeah your radio show which
is about bringing people together so try
to be nice are there any Democrats that
you think would throw their name into
the proverbial hat that would pose a
challenge for Republicans Stacey Abrams
uh
well then she'd have to vacate her
gubernatorial seat she won in 2018. so
that's it's comp the Abrams things
complicated I honestly don't know who
would fill the void but I don't think
he's running and here's why I don't
really I really don't think he's running
I don't think he can handle the rigors
of a full campaign and what I mean by
that is he didn't have to run in 2020.
the pandemic allowed him to stay home
watching Bonanza while the media
campaigned for him there were more Elvis
sightings in the summer of 2020 than
they were Joe Biden sightings and I
don't begrudge him that he's at an
advanced stage you know they say
everyone ages differently I believe he's
80 but he's like a young 95. I don't
think he could get out there and do it
and I know it's not going to be Kamala
because they're already at the stage of
the administration where she's getting
pretend jobs did you just see that video
of her being a Walmart greeter down at
the fish hatchery or whatever in the
Philippines yeah they don't even know
who she is they don't even know what
she's saying but this is a really really
quick thing there's a thing people with
kids do and you can speak to this you
can speak to this when you have a busy
house and you have kids getting in the
way you give them pretend jobs like hey
Lincoln do you want to go get the
monsters out of the washing machine he's
like oh boy monsters and he runs down to
the washing machine they're now doing
that with the vice president they're
like hey you want to get the monsters
off the dock she's down on the dock
saying hello it won't be her that's my
only guess yeah the Philippines is
deeply offended that that was the
comparison
do you think it's possible that Biden
isn't going to run
if somebody decides to step in and take
the car keys away from him before he
gets into the parking lot and I mean the
car keys of the the United States uh it
would probably be if and I'm speculating
obviously it'll probably be a family
member because it's his right he's the
president United States this is his to
decide any period whether regardless of
what people might say about him behind
closed doors
um but I want to talk just bring up
these talking points from Ron Claim
about what to tell that Uncle when he
comes at you at the Thanksgiving table
that's what they actually think about
conservatives that you got this dense
lunk head at the dinner table
um who can't see hear smell or taste
fictitious propaganda instead you know I
thought it was bad deplorables bitterly
clinging to their guns and bibles this
is bad and instead of talking at that
conservative uncle or aunt or child or
parent they should be listening right
now to Judge Judy put your listening
ears on and find out what financial
hardship from inflation is really like
and if they're not listening now they're
going to be listening a year from now
when the economy is in a deep recession
and home prices have fallen 30 to 50
percent they're going to be listen
listening and begging
conservatives to pay attention to the
Democrats
so Rachel I'd love to get your thoughts
on whether you think it's only liberals
that feel like they talk past
conservatives or if the conservatives
feel that about liberals because that's
my impressionally liberals okay well
then I guess don't answer that part of
the question listen do I think let's
talk about whether he's by the way if
you need talking points to explain I
mean no not what I'm saying they sent
that out yes you need talking points
your economy is not very good
um and and your foreign policy is also
not very good and that's why they do
that but can I talk about the decision
to run because I understand something
about that as a family it is a family
decision yeah so the Biden family is
sitting in a 20 million dollar donor
lent house yes on the on the heels of a
Vogue wedding where like the Hunter's
daughters like had this like Princess
Diana length tool Veil going off the
balcony into the Rose Garden they act
like they're royalty okay and they're
going to decide whether they're going to
of course they're all going to sit
around the table this is a family that
loves money and is willing to sell out
our country in order to get money of
course they're going to come out and say
yeah definitely let's run again let's do
it so I think they are going to run
again and I think it's shameful because
as they're making this decision they're
totally toned to have all of these moves
that they've just made this Vogue spread
so tone deaf Americans are suffering 40
let me just say this
40 there's a 40 percent increase in
first-time use of food banks and those
food banks the shelves are empty because
Americans don't have extra to give to
the phone Banks even though we're the
most generous people in the world these
are terrible times I have no idea how
they did so well in the midterms I
suspect it's a lot of the indoctrination
of young people we can talk about that
later and big Tech and big Tech but I I
I think they are running again I mean
Elon money they love the power and they
love the position my favorite point on
the talking points is at the end though
where it is you have to give 10 of your
mashed potatoes
[Laughter]
yeah things would be different if I
weren't leading this block and I would
have more talk shots
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else